This Europe in the 18th Century.
Smallpox is everywhere, 400,000 Europeans
are dying from it each year.
And there’s no cure, but there might be
hope… there’s a doctor who thinks he’s
found a way to fight the disease.
All you need to do is let him infect you with
some good, old-fashioned, cowpox-infected
pus.
Of course, there is this other doctor who
says, “Sure, you could do that, but it will
might make your face look like a cow’s.”
And the debate over vaccines began.
Today, vaccinations are fairly common.
Here’s a quick recap of how they work.
There are a number of different types of vaccines,
but they are all meant to do the same thing
- give your body the ability to fight a disease
without actually contracting it.
Whether they use a dead or weakened virus
or a toxin, the vaccine will make your body
activate T-lymphocytes and B-lymphocytes (T-cells
and B-cells).
Those are simply defensive white blood cells
that can remember how to battle those infections.
But let’s go back to 200 years ago.
The idea of using a virus to prevent getting
sick is older than you think.
In 10th century China, people would inhale
smallpox scabs in order to contract a mild
form of the disease and therefore gain immunity.
It was messy and didn’t always work and
also, gross.
Fast forward to 1796, British physician Edward
Jenner discovered something slightly less
gross but way more effective.
Milkmaids, for some unknown reason, were known
for never contracting smallpox.
Jenner believed they were gaining immunity
from cowpox, an unpleasant but not fatal disease.
Jenner tested his theory by taking cowpox
infected pus and using to to inoculate an
8-year-old boy.
This wasn’t his son, by the way..
Which yeah, does sound kind of messed up.
Especially when you realize he then later
exposed the boy to smallpox in order to confirm
his theory.
Luckily, the test was a success and Jenner
began treating more people (his own son included).
He called the process vaccination, using the
latin word, “vacca”, for cow.
He published his work in 1798, which was met
with...wide ridicule and repulsion.
Big surprise, putting pus from a diseased
animal into your body didn’t really fly
with everyone.
Another physician, William Rowley, made a
particularly outrageous claim that the vaccine
caused one boy to take on the features of
a cow.
It didn’t help that the vaccine wasn’t
perfect, either.
The smallpox vaccine has been plagued with
negative side effects throughout its history.
Even the modern day one had some potentially
serious side effects.
Plus, in the early 19th century, everything
is taking place before germ theory and proper
sterilization, so people would actually contract
other diseases from contaminated vaccines.
But despite its problems, the UK made vaccination
mandatory in the mid 1800s.
Britain actually became quite the fan of Jenner’s
work, with British Parliament eventually paying
him what now amounts to around a million dollars.
This was the start of the eradication of one
of humanity’s most notorious diseases.
In the 20th century, there were still 300
million deaths from smallpox worldwide.
But this century?
Zero.
Nothing.
The last recorded case was in 1978.
Today, the disease exists only in protected
labs.
All thanks to a curious scientist, some milkmaid
pus, and one really, really lucky kid.
Getting vaccinated is pretty normal, but what
about checking your poop?
Its actually more important than you think,
find why out in the is video.
So would you have taken the first vaccine
ever?
Let us know in the comments, don’t forget
to like this video, and be sure to subscribe
for more Seeker every day of the week.